and superhero get superhero outfits and
you liked yours
oh man yes yes I did oh thank you for it
more than you were meant to didn't you
did they offer you other clothes mm-hmm
yeah well let me ask you something if
they offered you that would you ever
take no I would never take it off yes I
but I fly generally anyway yeah yeah
monk if someone else is got a new suit
spider-man it's got a new suit oh yes
but you really like the suit right
I do yes because I can go to the
bathroom in it mainly you watch I Man 1
Robert wore the full suit and then if
you watch Iron Man 2 he wore like
American football pads that were red and
gold I'm on my fifth movie and I just
got a zipper so it's been a steady climb
but I know you're a good kid you know I
finally will you make enough movies
had you got to earn it it's one of those
obstacles that are put in front of you
who is Dave the Frog and why is Dave the
Frog got something to do with you
Dave your father's in in my math this is
what I hear what is that story right so
we have to do red carpets all the time
and take pictures and I find it very
awkward when they're all shouting at you
and stuff and a fan of mine tweeted a
picture of me saying Tom Holland looks
like he has a frog in his mouth when
he's taking paparazzi pictures and I
thought it was hilarious
so I reposted the picture which then
went viral and everyone found it
hilarious but then weeks go by and I'd
look at myself in the mirror and this is
you I think he's because I'm trying to
go for the chiseled jaw kind of look
it's just not working but Tom you did
the proper British thing you went to an
all-boys school it's that right yes yeah
I did yeah be well-behaved
no oddly for spider-man
they said you back to school oh well it
was a joke as a joke
they don't obviously understand my
British sarcasm I said wouldn't it be
funny if I went to an American high
school undercover to see what it would
be like to be in American high school
and waffle were like that's amazing
let's set it up so six weeks later I've
like with a backpack pencil case books
on my way to the school the Bronx School
of Science are just a school for genius
kids and believe me everyone I am not
know Jesus and yes why I enrolled in a
high school for three days I had like an
accent a fake name a backstory and they
named Ben Perkins who's my acting coach
for when I was a kid but they paired me
with a kid called a room and I was
supposed to be his brother or something
like that and Arun is an Indian kid and
when I came in here it was like
like yeah we're just distant brothers
from you know anyway this is a science
school they can figure things out but
then you did did you confide at the
people so I'm sitting next it's very
pretty girl in class and you have to go
through an exam process to get into this
school which obviously I didn't do and
she's like hey man what's your deal how
are you here let me tell you my secret
I'm actually um I'm actually spider-man
she's like dude you're [ __ ] nuts bro
no seriously I'm spider-man obviously
none of my movies that come out no one
knew about it it was a big secret so I
just looked like some Nutter put three
days and then disappeared
yeah she's laughing now she's
what's interesting about this is that
that's actually based on a true story
the the holograms and we're doing the
Holograms obviously they're not there
when you're doing them and I hadn't
really done a movie like this before you
know and so they're they're just I even
the first time I did it they were like I
didn't take it I didn't look at anything
I was just describing like you know
they're hot they're Holograms gonna be
spinning around in front of you and Tom
was like oh yeah they put like things
right in front of that thing and so I I
didn't know what to do they said just
dart your eyes around
[Laughter]
because in terms of the students oh
because what is I I shouldn't you know
you don't think of pepper that's kind of
a superhero person she was more human
but you did get to wear the suit yeah a
few times yeah yeah and was it in Iron
Man 2 3 3 3 Iron Man 3 Oh an end game
you're in it and then he gave himself
and and infinity and were you really in
the suit yeah as tom was saying they've
evolved the suit so an Iron Man 1 robert
was wearing huge armor and by the time
it got around to whatever the last one
was so mine didn't but I guess I don't
need a zipper
well that's seaming yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
like a subway with talcum powder and
people pulling them up and what are we
talking about right now
I had to definitely wiggle into it
mm-hmm yeah I've got some CGI and it's
like happen on a really tight wetsuit or
a scuba outfit yeah yeah but it feels so
nice being spied because this is your
third fourth third my third my third yes
so is it still as exciting as it was or
you bit kind of blase about being spied
about now no I mean you can't read I
mean I remember seeing Avengers one with
one of my best friend's Tom Hutton in
the cinema as a kid so excited and now
I'm in it you know I'm walking around
with Iron Man and Captain America and I
can now kind of call them peers and
stuff so it's it's still pretty surreal
but this one's definitely been a
whirlwind it's been insane and what
sweet is cuz I think a lot of actors
when they get roles like this they have
to say oh yeah no it's a thrill dude but
for you this is genuine could you post
these incredibly sweet pictures this is
you as a young boy
I mean you are playing with yourself
this one this is amazing you were I
think back at your house and you found
this yeah that was genuinely yours that
was my first ever spider-man costume
yeah which my lovely mum who said
tonight kept for me
and were you one of those kids you'd
like wore to funerals and weddings thing
still stinks today that can make that
thing wearable that the spider-man
outfit as we knew it is gone now
no well yes yes it is basically
essentially in this film I have a new
suit which Tony Stark gave me it's an
upgrade and it's too fantastical to
exist in real life so I essentially
there it is that's the first time I've
seen it where looks great you came
tonight is that Mikkel I don't know gram
okay
the black planet revolves around you
going on a school trip to Europe yes it
does yeah the film is a direct
continuation of avengers endgame so we
deal with the ramifications if the blip
of the death of Tony Stark sorry to
anyone who hasn't seen the film if you
haven't then you're living under a rock
wait we're in heaven you were in it
so the story is basically spider-man
trying to take a break he's trying to
hang up the spider-man suit and escape
the responsibility of being a superhero
but what he learns throughout the course
of the film is that that responsibility
isn't something you can run away from
and that's when we team up and we sort
of become best buds on an off-screen
[Laughter]
and we've got these elemental creatures
Jake Tom it sounds like was quite
unsympathetic to you while you were
filming would you get a little a little
peaky oh yeah we were shooting as well
we were shooting a scene and I got a I
got I got sick I was very nauseous
throughout the day and and in the middle
of the one of the takes I I I threw up
in the middle of the take and kept going
you know but that's how that's what
acting is all about I was sitting
opposite him and I was like how is he
doing that he's so good he looks so
tortured and so unwell and so I'm so
like like hurt and then he basically
just had a stomach bug and they actually
CGI'd the vomit out of the shot but if
you look in the movie in the movie at
there's my house math is just partially
open at one I'm kidding
[Applause]
that's the Marvel Universe painting out
the vomit
right some but my eyes were so
expressive
[Laughter]
[Music]
you